excuse me I was Nikki rod this guy sent
another videos didn't he no but Nikki
rod last week he was actually an ADC C
jujitsu champ
does is that familiar oh yeah yeah the
guy who makes the crazy videos
no that's j-rod Nikki rod was the guy
who had the pop oh no that guy's a
[ __ ] study trained with Gordon he's a
super stud
yeah yeah in a couple videos j-rod is
the guy with the panty on his head is a
semi local second place runner-up
peeping tom Jay Rossum the escaped
convict is on the run now Nikki Rob
hello a picture Nikki Rob man let's give
him some credit for Sean icky rods as
legit as they get he's sent in a couple
videos last week one of our video one of
them there he is with so if you view the
second picture cam that's like the best
jiu-jitsu player in the world which one
Gordon on the left
Wow now our then boys gonna pass the
drug test
run boys bodied up though dude that's
like a lot of gay men who are if you're
play if you're cheering but you also are
high on ya know what could a man be high
on dick pops a byproduct of penis
oh come semen okay say semen bro we're
talking about science
imagine that if a dude shows up and he's
had a half ounce of semen or something
that week the chain I mean that's pure
grade fuel fuel bro dude that is
straight rocket fuel bro that's like
when sonic dance I'll get that little
magic thing yeah how do you cheer
against that dude you don't yeah that's
a tough thing so that's the only thing
where I feel like they could have some
of these men or do or have an enhanced
peds enhance yeah performance-enhancing
drugs but shut out Nick your outlets
here and here he is and this is RIT
making out from prison here I guess a
tough week what's up - I'm Brendan
and gang gang buzzbuzz love you guys's
[ __ ] need some relationship advice does
this girl I've been really into this
jail I was a girl I'd be really into who
got a boyfriend and so once I found that
she had a boyfriend my dumb ass just
told her that I was gay she like man
look we hit things off the talk all the
time she thinks I'm gay and I know that
there's spark there I think the neighbor
thinks I'm gay either way she just broke
up with her boyfriend and I need to know
how to slide into those DMS help a boy
out thank you love you guys love you man
get some rest
[Laughter]
this like a young Jay Leno huh
he looks like a very young Jay Leno yeah
you know it's like a street Jay Leno
beautiful young man hell yeah I get for
you dude bodied up to dude you got it
you gotta go the religious route say you
start going to church you're not gay
anymore you don't like that like cheese
okay that's a great idea yeah I was gay
but I'm not I found Jesus yeah I'm not
gay yeah yeah give me a legal issue I'll
never recover from this this guy first
of all lay off the quaaludes brother you
got to drop off the ludes man boys I'm
Pluto right now we submit this video
yeah do you might not even be in a
relationship you might have never been
in a relationship you might be playing a
video game - you got you might be
playing the sim Center this way might
win on a sims K hole bro you gotta
tighten up that I've been watching too
much TV bro yeah so but I think you got
a move here okay you got an opportunity
you're friends with her you could always
say look I lied and said I was gay
because I didn't know what else to do
you know ken what do you think you could
say I was confused I thought I was into
dudes
since I met you now like chicks yeah you
you make me like chicks [ __ ] all these
dudes and then rip up a picture of some
dudes yeah right in front of her yeah
yeah these dude yeah terrible people's
magazine because she's also sick of
dudes right now cuz she just broke up
with that guy she's upset you can meet
her there meet her halfway meet her
halfway brother what do you think that
this good advisor
well it's hilarious I would say go with
what the inside because it's nice yeah
what exacty say to tell her that you
lied I think girls girls love it when
guys are vulnerable Wow plus it shows
that he cared enough about how she felt
about him that he would lie about being
gay yeah you could even get a friend to
say you guys hooked up saying your name
the whole time you talk about a male
friend yeah Tigers involved it's fine
who's there yeah just say that would be
like I wasn't going down to this Tiger
gonna be a fat pine it turns out just
the Tigers I'm into chicks but yeah man
I think we've young to salt ideas just
tell her you're not gay and since since
you met her you actually you're into
chicks and she's the one that converged
you or you went to church and because of
Jesus in your heart you don't go to hell
any like chicks amen
you got two solid choices there dude
amen so that helps yeah
praise Jesus praise Jesus PJ
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]